in a scene too gruesome to show
a camera pans from pools of blood
to a clearing with a pile of charred
bodies
we are deeply concerned by the reports
of the horrific killings of 11 people in
salangi township in northwest san yang
region in myanmar who were reportedly
shot and burnt by military on tuesday
morning in an apparent retaliation for
recent military militia attacks
credible reports indicate that five
children were among those people killed
at the scene in voices cracking with
emotion
men vow to avenge those that have died
it's a terror really it's really
something that
it would take so long
for the people of myanmar to
forget
myanmar's military have shown no mercy
for those that oppose the coup
on sunday as a flash mob of protesters
took to the streets a military truck
drove into the crowd at speed
five people killed
dozens more injured and arrested
since the coup in february myanmar's
military have faced increased opposition
from peaceful civilian protesters on the
streets
and increasingly from armed insurgent
groups
like this one the karenine nationality's
defense force
despite the harsh conditions in the
jungle training camps and the threat of
attack from the military
these new recruits felt they had little
choice
we never expected this revolution would
happen
at first we were protesting peacefully
but it didn't work and we never thought
we would be in the jungle fighting
against the military but it is what we
have to face
yet as the atrocities mount up the
protests continue
this flash mob hit the streets of yangon
as news of the sentencing of aung san
tsuchi to two years in jail was released
she like the other democratically
elected leaders of myanmar may now be
locked up but a younger generation is
taking up the fight against military
rule
tony cheng al jazeera